we're so excited um chris was kind
enough
uh to do transformations on
two of our vffs jamie and maria
and i can't wait to see them and we'll
get to them in just one minute but i was
wondering if i could um
pick your brain for a minute chris
please do
drew well you know when i would go to
salons
and i would change my hair which was
every other day because i tried every
cut color and style i would always bring
magazine references because i was
positive that was going to get something
lost in translation
i think a lot of the pictures people
probably bring in are the people you
the very hair stylists and giant stars
that you have done
like okay for example the glass hair
trend that's something that
everybody's obsessed with and you really
started that with kim k
if i can call it yeah kim k call it
kimmy yeah
um she um we actually started that back
in paris um a while ago and you know it
was just this very straight hair and we
tried to get it shinier and shinier and
then
it became you know a big thing and yeah
you're right i guess you know
i forget that the women i work with are
i guess so
known um and i kind of like it that way
just because you know we have a great
relationship they're amazing women
um and we love to create different looks
um so the fact that you know these
things become then a trend and sort of
take off it's always so exciting to see
but you know what you got it right drew
if you're ever going to go to the salon
and ask for a look taking a picture
is the perfect way to describe it to
your hairstylist because
it just stops you getting lost in
translation
oh and i've had those moments which is
why i bring those references
yeah it's a little scary can i just say
actually drew you've been uh you've been
on a few of the move boards before with
your back in the 90s at the clips
you had some dudes you've had some looks
throughout the years i love it
thank you i tend to think like hair
first
uh as certainly as an actor i would find
my way into a lot of
characters with the hair first i was
like
what is that frame and you know
it was just a really good entry point um
and i always love people like barbra
streisand and jane fonda
and madonna and lady gaga david bowie
those
sort of um you know and kim kay car
calls you a transformationalist
like person because
it does change you it changes your
attitude your confidence level it gives
you kind of a new
attitude and character hair is a
big thing and it's an important thing
yeah
absolutely yeah what's a good product to
get that
trend of glass hair um one of my
favorite go-to's
is the dream coat it's colorwhale's
dreamcoat it's a transformative kind of
i guess prep to the hair you put on wet
hair and it basically changes the whole
texture of hair once it's dried and it
also has like a waterproof technology so
it has a sealant against any water
or humidity because everyone knows
that's the worst thing you do your hair
and you go outside and
the weather changes it so that's one of
my go-to's for glassette for sure
um but you know just go back to what you
were saying draw actually about how you
get ready for characters it's funny
because
i guess every time i work with the
clients that i work with the first thing
i always say is like
okay who do you want to be you know for
example if it's jlo i'm like
is it jenny from the block is she movie
jayla
is she you know uh performance jayla
because everything is
like a different character that you're
kind of stepping into and everything
tells a story
which i think is i guess why i started
doing hair i mean i used to do my mom's
hair when i was nine years old because
i mean ironically i used to try and make
a lot like a hollywood star because
creatively i liked it but when i told
her to stand up and look in the mirror
i would see her shoulders go back and
she would forget for a minute she was a
mum of five and she would
feel herself and i remember that feeling
was like so infectious for me making
people feel good about
the way they look and you know kind of
giving them that alter ego if you like
i guess it's still why i do it you know
it's still that kind of process of
just making people look and feel great
because that's when the magic happens
right
it does change the body language it
changes the confidence
and it changes the inner dialogue
100 i don't know what to take it a step
further i even saw it like
going a stage but like i actually
started to work with cancer patients
that's how i started to work with wigs
like now i work with which celebrities
but back then it was
working with these women that i knew
that were really strong women and they
were
regular clients they had cancer they
lost their hair and they would come in
and they would have lost their identity
and my job was to like
give them their identity back and make
them feel like they could somehow you
know
face the day and it was almost like
emotional medicine and there's so much
behind it but honestly just
you know the main story is that great
hair really can
you know make your day feel better and
just make you be able to go ahead
with it with more confidence which is
you know for me why i do what i do i i
love it
some of our vffs um wanted to come to
you
uh and have you come to their rescue
shall we take a quick look at jamie
let's we had some fun
we had some fun with this i can't wait
to see
hi my name is jamie as a busy mom of
five
and a full-time nurse especially during
the pandemic it's been
super challenging to find time for
myself one thing that i really really
need help with is my hair
i'm totally clueless when it comes to
blow drying my hair so my hair is super
thin i know there has to be some
products out there or
styling tips that can help me get some
volume maybe get some lift up here
drew and chris i really really need some
help in the hair department can you help
me
jamie hi good how are you i'm so excited
to do this with you
so first of all what we're going to do
is we're going to take the color while
erase the root volumizing spray
we're just going to spray this through
the roots just all the roots
get some love you should have a round
brush take that section
lift it right up in the air and then
just literally wrap it
around what we're going to do now jamie
is
because the hair is not wet it's not
going to take long to dry in all we're
going to do is dry the product in
you should get that space framing kind
of volume at the front but i just kind
of put the velcro roller in
and let it sit if you leave them in five
or ten minutes it's great
jamie we're gonna take the texturizing
spray and just blast it through the
roots now
this basically just gives your hair a
little bit more volume
at this point i just like to blast the
hair dryer through and just shake it all
out
just using your fingers to shake out the
waves jamie i can't wait for you to show
this look to drew
i think if this is a bit of a show
stopper
jamie is here to show us her final hair
transformation i'm sorry i'm mesmerized
jamie welcome
how are you take you out jamie
you did it your bombshell got it
love it you look so
gorgeous thank you i mean
this is very different hair than
where you started yeah
i i i mean give us a swish let's see
that but let's see her
move that's it i can't believe
that my fine thin hair could get so much
volume
but after your lesson chris i
my it goes back and forth anywhere but
the biggest thing i think was
uh realizing i could style my hair dry
just put a little product
in there and do it and it looks great
and jamie we did it really fast didn't
we we literally turned that around
in a few simple steps yeah so simple and
jamie
you are a knockout a knockout seriously
all right thank you jamie um we're gonna
take a look at chris's
next hair transformation here's maria
take a look
hello everyone my name is maria i'm an
18 year old college student for the past
15 years
my hair has been the same honestly i'm
getting bored of it i recently just
turned 18
and i really needed to feel my most
confident self i
am the biggest fan of ariana grande and
i think
everybody knows her signature ponytail
that she does
i think perfecting this ariana ponytail
really gives me
that boost of confidence that i need
drew chris
can you help me maria hi chris oh my
gosh i'm so excited
i can't wait to show you how to get this
ariana grande inspired ponytail
take the hairspray and we're effectively
just going to spray it throughout the
roof
section of the hair using the cool
favorite hairspray um i am an ambassador
this is my favorite stuff so listen
it's all about the cheekbone to get the
perfect ponytail placement you want to
follow this cheekbone
wow i can already see like a difference
okay so a bungee elastic looks a bit
like this guys
i put the hook in underneath the
ponytail and then wrap it around
i tie it again with a second elastic
we're going to tie it
an inch above the ponytail that we just
did
we have this magic powder so this is the
color well root touch-up powder
what i do is i go in and just fill the
hairline out
perfect all right so what we're going to
do then is just take a small strand of
hair like this just unlock we're going
to wrap it around the ponytail
ariana grande style wow maria that
ponytail
looks amazing i did not wait
[Applause]
chris has changed my life he's changed
the game
for my hair i mean like look at it i
feel beautiful i feel so confident and
amazing
i love that chris she looks insane
she looks so good yeah it was so simple
and easy
and i didn't realize what a beautiful
ponytail in like
so professional could take such less
time and you guys could do it too in the
comfort of your own home
i mean it's so easy and simple i just
think you look gorgeous maria thank you
so much and
chris um you used some of the products
from color wow with jamie and maria and
you're the global creative director for
that brand
and guess what vff's you are all going
home with a detox
kit from color wow and that includes
some
amazing goodies for your hair